[Music]
Fabiana has ability to morph because
he's always learning new things so I
think I wouldn't you know be just to him
if I would say that his chances are less
than 45% I definitely hope you'll help
in this match he is a tremendous player
and I like him assess it's a person too
despite despite him wishing wishing me
to do better in all my tournaments and I
think it's really hard to do not call
Magnus a favorite no matter how much you
love America or love whatever else
Fabiana represents so I think we have to
give him 30 percent chance well it's
it's probably well it's hard to say the
closest match because my reaction
already brought him to a tie-break but
let's say this match I expect to be very
competitive but also I think the games
will be very hard-fought and open
karyakin
and to some degree I we tried a more
solid approach not loving Magnus a lot
of space that was kind of the idea we
had but I think Fabiana will take it to
much harder and it's nice that the two
of them are the closest interacting that
Magnus has ever faced in a match I feel
the Fabiano hast one of the classical if
it goes too rapid I think that Magnus is
probably 95% or better to win in the
rapid and blitz simply based on the
historical fact that Magnus pretty much
never loses a tiebreaker and even the
tiebreaker he played against Sergei in
the last World Championship he he really
dominated that and I think I would
consider surgery to be a vastly superior
rapid and blitz player to Fabiano's so
Fabiano has to win a class
I think it's gonna be very close much I
would write Magnus is a very slight
favorite 55 or 60 percent favorites if
they were going to play a hundred
matches
I would definitely favor Magnus it's
someone much and I think that Fabiano
will rise to the challenge and give - as
hard a time as he can possibly get
Carson of course is still number one in
the world is just very in the world
forward will be Magnus but I hope Karan
will win I hope just world will change
something some new world champion will
come I hope her on a whirlwind I think
his models chance is better because he
is still number one and he is very
strong he's a very dangerous opponent
for Marni's and that he if he is able to
come to the match like him in his top
shape then I'm pretty sure it will be
very close much it is clear from the
last tournaments that he he's keeping
his high level this form yeah I think it
will be very very close match very
interesting finish
I think it's 45 percent for Corona and
55 for 4 - but at the same time I wish
Fabiana will win because we all need
some change the changes and we are all
very tired of Mongoose and if there will
be some changes we will very